Україна відноситься до маловодних країн.
І ті водосховища, які є на руслі Дніпра,
виконують зараз дуже важливу роль
акумуляторів прісної води.
Відмовитись від цих водосховищ
на сьогодні неможливо.
Ми лише можемо зробити все для того,
щоб наші водосховища були в належному стані.
Наше завдання як науковців —
знайти причини і говорити про можливі способи
покращення стану водосховища.
Водорості завжди є у водоймі,
але ми їх не бачимо,
тому що вони знаходяться
в дуже малій кількості.
Розмножуючись, ці маленькі водорості
стають видимими.
Навіть просто підходячи до водойми,
ми бачимо, що вона змінила своє забарвлення.
І ми вже можемо говорити,
що залежно від тої кількості біомаси, яка є у воді,
це буде називатися цвітінням.
Ми отримали грант Національної академії наук,
яка з 2018 року дійсно почала виділяти
серйозні кошти молодим науковцям
на створення або дослідницьких лабораторій,
або дослідницьких груп.
За допомогою цього проєкту ми маємо можливість
дослідити Київське та Канівське водосховища.
Як результат всього проєкту за два роки, ми сподіваємося,
що досягнемо нашої мети
і зможемо встановити певні закономірності,
які існують між водними рослинами,
цвітінням та рибопродуктивністю водосховищ.
Тарас не є співробітником Інституту гідробіології,
однак ми мали можливість його залучити для того,
щоб він міг виконати обстеження водойми дроном.
Потім ці знімки з дрону зможуть
співставити із знімками з супутника.
І зможуть дійсно розрахувати кількість
водних рослин, які знаходяться в товщі води.
Процес цвітіння води цікавить нас
як науковців з дуже великої кількості сторін.
І однією із цих сторін якраз є пошук способів,
що можна робити із цим процесом.
Й одним із варіантів був взаємозв'язок
вищих водних рослин,
їхній вплив на процеси цвітіння.
Також ми брали зоопланктон.
Ігор досліджував видовий склад риби для того,
щоб також потім можна було говорити,
в який спосіб впливають водні рослини
на рибопродуктивність.
У заростях ловлю цьогорічних мальків риб.
У такий спосіб можна буде бачити,
яка риба тут нерестилась.
Я потім буду цих мальків визначати під мікроскопом.
Зараз складно сказати, що це за види.
Їх уже декілька штук піймалось.
Ми практично ж складаємося переважно з води,
як і всі живі організми.
Тому вода — це основа нашого життя.
Ми п'ємо воду, опосередковано,
звісно, не з самого Дніпра,
але це із підземними водами пов'язано.
І всі водойми, навіть маленькі озера, маленькі річечки, —
кожну з них потрібно оберігати,
не допускати їхнього забруднення й зникнення.
У воді має бути правильне співвідношення
азоту й фосфору.
І саме порушення цього співвідношення
призводить до явища цвітіння.
Однією з причин того, що до водойм може
надходити велика кількість фосфатів,
є використання великої кількості
мийних засобів, які містять фосфати.
Це порошки, засоби для миття
посуду, шампуні тощо.
Тобто будь-які з цих мийних засобів у межах
нашого законодавства раніше не контролювалися.
З цього року вже почалися зміни в законодавстві.
І поступово до 2023 року така кількість фосфатів буде
або заборонена, або настільки мінімізована,
що вона не матиме шкідливого впливу.
Іншим чинником, який може провокувати
велику кількість фосфору і азоту у водоймах,
є змиви із сільськогосподарських полів.
Після дощів або паводків ці речовини змиваються
з сільськогосподарських полів у водойми.
Водойма стає перенасиченою,
зокрема сполуками азоту і фосфору.
І це також буде потім, у період великого
прогрівання води, спричиняти явище цвітіння.
Роль Дніпра в нашій країні неможливо оцінити.
Вона просто неоціненна.
І це чудово, що в нас є така річка.
Кожна водойма є відображенням того стану,
як до неї ставляться ті жителі,
які перебувають на узбережжі цієї водойми.
Будь-яка наша дія потім призведе
до певного наслідку.
І лише повага до тих водойм,
на берегах яких ми перебуваємо,
призведе до того, що ці водойми
служитимуть нам та приноситимуть користь.
І ми зможемо успішно, здорово будувати
наше життя на берегах цих водойм,
прогресивно рухаючись лише вперед.